a christmas tradition this year with a
deeper meaning
the queen giving her annual message with
a single photograph of her and prince
philip on her desk
wearing the same sapphire chrysanthemum
brooch she wore as a newlywed in a
tender tribute to her husband on the
first christmas without him
for anybody spending christmas without
the person they'd spent the whole their
lives with will be tough i think the the
emblem of the brooch that she's wearing
is so special and typical of her
recognition of the fact that he's still
with her in spirit
the queen usually hosts her family on
her sandragomen state but yet again the
virus has scuppered the festive
gathering
this is the second year the queen will
spend christmas at windsor castle
because of covid and the first to spend
without her husband in a very long time
but she won't be alone she'll be joined
by the prince of wales and the duchess
of cornwall on christmas day
her christmas message will have a nod to
the value of community in a difficult
year so i want you to be really happy
with it
featuring carol sung by an amateur choir
my thing is within the choir is not
about the singing it's about the
community and it's about the connection
that they make and the support network
that they develop whilst being there so
to come here and do this tonight
is just the most amazing thing for them
hanging on the monarchs tree are these
white and gold stars your stars that you
made
made by the children from the royal
school in windsor we made stars and they
went on the queen's christmas tree
and the queen loved it yeah
she did
the royal family may not all be together
this christmas but they are marking it
in their own way with the duchess of
cambridge showcasing her piano skills
for the first time
and the duchess of cornwall and the
prince of wales reading from their
favorite festive books
may we wish each and every one of you a
very happy christmas
god bless us everyone
with hope that next christmas will be
better
milena vassalini ridge sky news